hello everyone
and welcome to our live mac site
sponsored webinar
overview of flexible clinically
adaptable
non-viral approaches to car tcr
methodologies
my name is leslie eschinger and i am the
director of marketing from upsite
i will be your moderator for today's
engaging session
i would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive so we
encourage you to participate by
submitting questions at any time
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click on the send button if at any
time you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window
our speaker for today's session will be
rama shivakumar
a senior research scientist and customer
application specialist at backslight
for rama's complete biography please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
during today's event rama will highlight
powerful case studies
that demonstrate the successful use of
maxite's clinically validated scalable
electroporation system
in a variety of applications she will
discuss
next-generation car approaches compare
detailed case studies of both autologous
and allogeneic therapeutic solutions
and will examine the advantages of a
scalable non-viral approach
throughout the development and
manufacturing process
without further delay let me turn this
session
over to miss rama shivakumar
thank you so much for the kind
introduction leslie
hello everyone in this webinar
we will discuss an overview of a
flexible
clinically adaptable non-viral approach
to car tcr methodologies
the talk is organized in the following
segments
we will first go over who we are as a
company
and how our technology has provided
an enabling solution to our customers
research
and clinical needs to illustrate this
we have included four specific case
studies
in the first case study we will go over
the development of a mesothelion
specific
mrna car for both resting and activated
t-cell therapies in the second case
study
we will illustrate how this technology
was used to engineer
nk cells for car therapies we will then
talk about the manufacture of transposon
car t cells and in our fourth case study
we will go over ways to improve the
efficacy
of car tcr therapies with
gene editing we will then round off the
talk
with a summary
let us first go over who we are
and how we are driving the next
generation
of cell based medicines
maxite is a global cell therapy
and life sciences company that was
founded in 1999.
we are headquartered in gaithersburg
maryland
maxide's powerful scalable flow
electroporation technology
is currently being used to engineer a
variety of cell types to enable
research clinical and commercial
applications once the transfection
process
is optimized at the research stage the
high efficiency
reproducible performance can be
translated
to a clinical or commercial scale
rapidly without the need for
re-optimization
the same unifying technology can
therefore be
used to take a product from concept
to clinic maxsite's
electroporation platform is branded as
expert the expert platform is designed
to deliver
high transfection efficiencies and
viabilities
to give you a potent self-therapy
product
that is efficacious and reproducible
which can then enable the rapid clinical
translation
of your research to a therapy
the expert is a family of three
instruments
the atx the sdx and
the gtx all these instruments are sleek
with the touchscreen and enhanced
software user interface
occupying very little space on the lab
bench
the atx is research focused used for
small
and medium scale static transfections
the stx is a scalable flow
electroporation device
that can be used for transient protein
production
and also in the production of vaccines
and other biologics
the gtx is the clinically validated
scalable flow electroporation device
which has
21 cfr compliance has
a cgmp compliance and also
an iso certification
we offer many consumables that are
compatible with the expert devices
these are called processing assemblies
and one can use them to transfect
a range of 75 000 cells to
over 20 billion cells the transfection
volumes
range from as low as 15 microliters of
cells
in the smallest chamber up to 100 mils
of cells
in our large flow electroporation
chamber
with these instruments and processing
assemblies
we have enabled a number of partners
like ksq
sangamo u-pen crisper therapeutics
allergene and kite to name a few
to scale very quickly from r d to
patient treatment
we have over 120 clinical licenses
we are engaged in over 90 clinical
programs
and we have 11 commercial licenses
in the first case study we will talk
about
the development of a mesothelion
specific
mrna car in resting and activated t
cells we will show work that was done in
dr carl
june's lab at u-pen and we will also
show
data that was generated from math site
in collaboration with johns hopkins
university
the goals illustrated in this case study
were to determine the therapeutic
potential
safety and feasibility of mrna cars
directed against mesothelion inactivated
t
cells and to develop a commercial
product
with a streamlined cgmp compliance
strategy
for manufacturing pbmcs transfected
with mesothelion specific mrna card
to determine the on target of tumor
toxicity
of this miso mrna car a
clinical trial was designed where a
cohort of patients were infused
repeatedly
with the mrna karti product and the
anti-tumoral clinical response
was monitored over time to develop a
commercial product from mac site called
as karma
we simplified the complexity and cost of
manufacturing of cardi cells
where the anti-human miso car mrna
was directly transfected into pbmcs
without prior activation or expansion
in the pre-clinical study that is
discussed
the karma product was first
characterized in vitro
and then followed by activity in
xenograft models
patients meeting the eligibility
criteria
underwent a large volume apheresis to
isolate
t cells the t cells were activated by
the addition of
anti cd3 and anti cd28 beads
and cultured for 10 to 12 days in a cell
culture medium
supplemented with human serum the
expanded t
cells were then electroporated with mrna
encoding an anti-mesothelion
ss1 scfe car
using the maxcite gt system the cardi
miso cells were then cryopreserved
in an infusible cryoprotectant
supplemented media
a dosing regimen was determined where
repeated
anti-mesocar mrna doses
were first given for several weeks
intravenously before switching
to intra-tumoral infusions several
assays were performed to determine the
efficacy
of cardi infusions in vivo trafficking
prior to the commencement of the
intra-tumoral injections
trafficking of karti meso cells to the
tumor tissues
was evaluated by qpcr analysis
samples from blood aciditis fluid
and tumor biopsies were collected at
several time points
the qpcr results revealed that the cardi
miso cells had traffic to the tumor
sites
when infused intravenously
the ct scan a ct scan done
after the commencement of intra-tumoral
injections
showed a distinct reduction in tumor
burden
epitope spreading when a tumor
disintegrates
a number of new epitopes are expressed
on the surface
these are then subject to attack by
other members of the immune system like
b cells nk cells and macrophages
the massive immune response results
in tumor elimination to demonstrate this
protein lysates from miso expressing
cell lines
were transferred onto a nitrocellulose
membrane
and blotted with the serra from the
patients
the appearance of new bands on the
western blot
was consistent with epitope spreading
the results of the preclinical and
clinical studies from dr carl june's lab
proved that the mrna car approach was
safe
and feasible with no off target effects
in patients
the process was then further optimized
at mac site
to reduce timelines by using resting t
cells as a viable options for the miso
mrna car therapy this led to
our own commercial product called karma
where pb and species are isolated from
patients
with the miso mrna car and then frozen
in appropriate media until infusion
into patients
the karma car construct is a second
generation
car it is a cd3 zeta 41db car
directed against human mesothelioma
the karma cells induce target specific
killing
of mesothelion expressing ovarian tumor
cells like
id8 cells in vitro
the id8 target cells grew in monolayers
when co-cultured with control
cells however when cultured in the
presence of karma h
meso cells the idh cells
realized and the only remaining cells
were the karma h meso cells
with small aggregates which was
consistent
with activated t-cell morphology
to evaluate the activity of karma-h meso
cells
in vivo mice were challenged with id8
mesotumor cells stably expressing
luciferase
on day four after inoculation the karma
meso cells were thought
and injected into mice intraperitoneally
the mice were imaged once a week
mice injected with 1e7 karma h
meso cells showed similar tumor signals
in the abdomen
which indicated that the treatment had
no effect
at such a low cell dose
in contrast mice injected with only
eight karma each meso cells showed
significantly lower tumor signals
in the abdomen at all time points
a single ip injection of karma h meso
cells
effectively controlled ovarian tumor
growth
in vivo but this treatment was
short-lived
to overcome the limitation of transient
expression of
car on t cells the study tested whether
repeated
ip injection of karma h meso cells
is more effective in ovarian tumor
growth control
the results showed that six weekly
intraperitoneal injections of 5e7 karma
h meso cells
was more effective in controlling tumor
growth than three
weekly ip injections of 5d7 karma h
meso cells this is now an
open ongoing clinical trial
in the second case study we will
illustrate
how this technology was used to engineer
nk cells for car therapies against
acute lymphocytic leukemia or all
and acute myeloid leukemia or aml
the data presented in this case study
comes from two sources
from dr dario campana's work at national
university of singapore and ank
therapeutics
in ireland the all or acute lymphocytic
leukemia
model presented in this case study is
the work done by dr
dario campana's group at the national
university of singapore
dr kampana wanted the option of
modifying
large numbers of nk cells with the
anti-cd19
car mrna in a very short time
because then the infusion of the car nk
product into patients could happen in a
few
hours after collection with minimum
x vivo manipulation and no extra cell
culture the data presented for the aml
or the acute myeloid leukemia model
was generated by onc therapeutics in
ireland
to develop a clinically viable car
nk product for aml targeting
cd 38 it was essential to knock out the
inherent
cd38 in nk cells this
prevents nk cell frataside
this was then followed by the
electroporation of an
affinity optimized anti-cd38
car mrna the goal of onc therapeutics
is to finally make a rapidly scalable
consistent batch manufacture of
anti-cd38k
nk product at a low cost that can be
rapidly translated
into the clinic
the figure on the left is the design of
the car molecule that doctor companions
group tested in this study
the design represents a second
generation car molecule
with an anti-cd19 specificity
the signaling capacity is provided by
the cd3 zeta
and 401 bb moyets in a set of nine
experiments
dr kampano's group directly compared the
transfection efficiency
of the anti-cd19 bbz car
in primary and expanded nk cells from
the same donors
the bar graph in the middle shows the
percentage of nk
cells expressing the anti-cd19 bbz
mrna as determined by flow cytometry
24 hours post electroporation
the figure on the right shows the flow
cytometric
density plots that illustrate the
expression of the anti-cd19 bbz
mrna car in three out of the nine donors
overall the percentage of cells
expressing the car
was consistently higher in xvivo
expanded nk
cells the median cell viability
after electroporation was 90 for the
expanded cells
and 91 for the primary nk
cells the data for viabilities is not
shown
while the receptor expression by
retroviral transduction required
two rounds of transduction on two
consecutive days
the mrna electroporation was
accomplished in one hour
and resulted in high car expression
the efficiency of car expression
following retroviral transduction was
around
60 percent whereas the efficiency of car
expression
following mrna transfection was around
87 percent
max site electroporation was rapid
simple
and dr campana's group was able to
overcome
viral transduction manufacturing
limitations
by using the maxcite gt system
in the graph depicted on the left those
cells
expressing the anti-cd19 bbc
car mrna exerted a much higher
cytotoxicity
against a cd19 positive b-cell lineage
cell line
than the mock transpected cells the
expanded nk cells
expressing the cd19 car mrna
were more cytotoxic than the primary nk
cells
expressing the car mrna
the figure on the right shows the flow
cytometric density plots
from two different experiments where the
expanded nk cells from two different
donors
were electroporated in the absence or
presence
of the anti-cd19 bbc mrna
the cells were co-cultured in the
presence of a cd19 positive cell line
in a one-to-one ratio the results
indicate
that the nk cells expressing the
anti-cd19 bbz mrna
produced a two-fold higher level of
interferon gamma
in a step towards the clinic the
scalability of the maxsite gt platform
was assessed
followed by in-vivo adaptive transfer
to assess anti-tumor activity
mrna electroporation using large-scale
electroporation
resulted in 82 efficiency
similar to efficiencies seen in the
previous small scale experiments
mice were injected with an all tumor
line
followed two days later by the injection
of
engineered or unengineered nk sets
those mice receiving the nk cells
expressing the anti-cd19 car
mrna displayed a 10-fold lower tumor
burden
when compared to the mice receiving the
control
nk cells despite the transient nature of
mrna expression
the engineered nk cells exhibited
impressive
in vivo anti-tumor activity
in the aml study or the acute myeloid
leukemia study
the main approach of onc therapeutics
was to genetically modify
nk cells to express the affinity
optimized
anti cd38 car that can effectively
eliminate
cd38 high expressing aml
glass it was however important to first
knock out the cd 38 on nk cells
using crisper casino this was done
on day 5 following expansion
the cd38 knockout was then assessed by
flow cytometric analysis on day 30.
following this the affinity optimized
anti-cd38
car mrna was introduced into the cd38
knocked out nk cells via electroporation
the in-vitro functionality of the
affinity optimized
anti-cd38 car mrna expressing
cd38 knockout nk cells
was then assessed in an in vitro assay
the dot plots on the left show a 90
knockout of cd38 post
electroporation the dot plots on the
right show a
42 expression of the anti-cd
38 car mrna 20 hours
post electroporation in the cd38
knocked out primary donor derived
expanded nk cells 100 micrograms per ml
of car mrna
was electroporated in this study using
the maxcite gt system
the dot plots represent results of the
cytotoxicity assays
with mock or car mrna electroporated
cd38 knocked out nk cells
co-cultured with aml cd38 expressing
cell lines
like thp-1 and kg-1a target cells
the car expressing cd38
knocked out nk cells show enhanced
cytotoxicity the data presented
here are from dr shigeki yagyu's lab
dr shigeki yagyu is a professor at the
department of pediatrics
at the kyoto prefectural university of
medicine
in kyoto japan
dr yagyu wanted to develop a non-viral
hearty methodology
using the piggyback transposon system
for the treatment of pediatric
rhabdomyosarcoma in japan
in japan one cannot use viral vectors
like lentiviruses
or gamma retroviruses in clinical trials
sendai viruses are used on occasion but
this too has several drawbacks
dr yagyu was looking to develop a highly
versatile clinical manufacturing
protocol
with reduced costs and timelines to
develop
a cheaper safer functionally better
transposon car directed against the
efferent b
receptor this case study outlines the
generation
of the anti-efferent b receptor car t
cells
and also an anti-cd19 car t product
in pbmcs and their in vitro cytotoxic
potential
as a preliminary experiment conditions
for dna loading was
optimized in resting pbmcs
a gfp plasmid was used as a dna control
increasing the dna concentration
resulted in higher transfection
efficiencies
as demonstrated the higher percent gfp
in the facts plots increasing the dna
concentration resulted
in lower viabilities as seen in the
seven
aad staining showing the effects of dna
toxicity
once dna loading into pbmcs was
optimized
the core transfection of piggyback
transposon and transpose was addressed
in an
experiment a total of 15 micrograms
a one-to-one ratio of piggyback
transposon
and piggyback transposes was
electroporated
into pbmc's at varying cell densities
ranging from one e eight cells per ml 48
cells per ml
and eight e8 cells per ml
facts analysis was done at 48 hours to
determine
buyabilities and also carb positive
cells
the carb positive cells increased with
increasing cell densities
the results were best at 88 cells per ml
with the number of carb positive cells
at 52 percent
and high viabilities at 86 percent
here the maxide process with high cell
density electroporations
allowed for conservation of resources
40 million pbmcs were transfected using
the mac site
optimize protocol with the piggyback
transposon
and transpose the cells were then
expanded on a layer of
uv-irradiated feeder cells along with
the cytokine cocktail
containing il-7 and il-15
at the end of the 14-day expansion
process
three e8 efferent b-car t cells were
retreat
they were also able to retrieve 4e8 cd19
car t cells as well
using the same protocol
after the 14-day expansion protocol
the facts analysis showed that the
percentage of the efferent b
car t cells were around 67 percent
and the percentage of cd19 car t cells
were 82 these cells
also conformed to the desired naive
memory t cell phenotype and they also
showed
a non-exhaustive phenotype with no
expression
of the pd1 checkpoint inhibitor
the potency and durability of the
piggyback engineered efferent big car t
cells were assessed using
an in-vitro co-culture with the target
from b expressing rhabdomyosarcoma cell
line
rh30 efferent b car t cells were plated
at a one to one
or a two to one ratio with 10 000
rh-30 cells and incubated for three days
an additional 10 000 rh30 cells
were added to the culture in the second
and third round
and the number of live tumor cells were
determined
each time three days later
the rh-30 cells were rapidly killed
during a second and third round
challenge
demonstrating the sustained activity of
the efferent b
cardi cells in our fourth case study
we will go over ways in which the maxi
technology can be
used in generating applications
to improve the efficacy of car and tcr
therapies
and also how this technology enables the
making
of an allogeneic car t product
recent advances in gene editing
technology
allow for the manufacture of carpi cell
therapies
starting from healthy donor leukophresis
material
in which the quantity and quality of the
t cells can be pre-selected to decrease
the number of allo-reactive t-cells
and prevent graft versus host disease
endogenous tcr alpha beta and beta-2
micro-tubulin genes
are knocked out using crispr cas9 talens
or other gene editing tools the maxcite
gt
system has been shown to knock out the
track locals
with greater than 95 percent efficiency
in both jerked cells as well as
activated t
cells the cas9 and guide rnas can be
co-delivered
as rna or rnp to get
a high degree of knockout efficiency
without compromising the viabilities of
the target cells
the gene editing efficiencies are
carefully optimized
with a linear correlation between the
total energy delivered
and the gene editing efficiency
researchers at washu and saint louis
were able to achieve
over 95 percent multiplex gene editing
efficiencies
using the mac site platform the
conditions were first
optimized to maximize the gfp
mrna transfection efficiencies in
activated t
cells before designing a highly
efficient
multiplex rnp approach to knock out the
track
and cd7 loci to up to 95
very pleased with these results the
research group at washu
went on to test whether these gene
editing efficiencies
scaled up seamlessly when a larger
volume of cells
were electroporated in a bigger
processing assembly
the compelling data here shows that the
process is
effortless and the high efficiency gene
editing
is consistent and reproducible when you
scale up from the smaller
oc 100 processing assembly to a larger
r 1000 processing assembly
in a complex experiment researchers at
the seattle children's hospital
used the maxi platform to engineer
activated t cells using a mrna
aav co-delivery method cas9
and mutant adenoviral helper proteins
were delivered as mrna followed by
the aav delivery of multiplex guides
for the simultaneous knockout of track
and a checkpoint inhibitor
tim3 mutant adenoviral helper proteins
were mainly used to maintain a cellular
dna repair environment that is conducive
to gene editing
eighty percent of tim3 and 65
of track were knocked out simultaneously
in this study genome editing when
combined with tcr
immunotherapy has the potential to
increase the potency
and safety of the engineer t cells
the phase one clinical trial illustrated
here
used the math site gt platform to
electroporate
patient t cells with crispr casino and
rnp's
containing three single guide rnas
targeting the track
trbc and pd1 loci
the edited t cells were then transduced
with a lentivirus
expressing a tcr specific for the new
york eso one
tumor antigen the engineered t
cell product was then infused into the
patient
the engraftment and persistence of the
edited t
cells in the patients were monitored
over time
autonomous t cells from two myeloma
patients
and one sarcoma patient were obtained by
apheresis
illuterated washed and enriched for t
lymphocytes electroporation of the rnp
complexes containing equimolar mixtures
of cas9
with single guide rnas for track trpc
and pd1 were performed as per math
site's standard
operating procedures the rnp
complexes were mixed with the desired
concentration of t
cells and loaded carefully into a
processing assembly
and then electroporated using an
optimized
protocol on the maxsite gt instrument
the cells were then cultured in the
appropriate media
with il-7 and il-15 at 30 degrees
centigrade for a time
following the gene editing step the
cells were then transferred
to a 37 degree centigrade incubator
activated with cd3 cd28 beads
and then transduced with a lentiviral
vector
encoding the tcr specific for new york
eso1 antigen
the cells were subsequently expanded in
a wave bioreactor
with il-7 and il-15 until harvest day
the final genetically engineered t cell
product
was termed as nice which referred to the
new york eso one tcr transduced
xxx gene edited t cells
at the end of the 8 to 12 day expansion
protocol
over 1 e 10 cells were obtained
from each patient
the digital pcr approach was used to
determine the gene editing efficiencies
the results vary depending on the single
guide rna used
the gene editing efficiency for the
track locus was 45
the gene editing efficiency for the trb
locus was 15
and the gene editing efficiency for the
pd1 locus
was 20 percent at the asgct meeting this
year
dr carl dune affirmed that the reagents
used for gene editing have come a long
way from the first generation reagents
that were used in this study they are
now getting
over 90 gene editing efficiencies for
the three loci
as they embark on expanding this trial
to include a larger cohort of patients
the high fidelity on target editing for
track
and pd-1 was well over 99
it was a little lower for the trb locus
but then the gene editing efficiency was
lower for this locus as well
when the nice cells were co-cultured
with the target cells expressing the new
york eso one tumor antigen
in an in vitro cytotoxicity assay
the nice cells demonstrated potent
antigen-specific cytotoxicity
over a wide range of effector to target
ratios
in fact the nice cells showed even
greater cytotoxicity
than the control cells that expressed
the transgenic tcr
but were electroporated without the
crisper reagents
in another assay to assess the
polyfunctional profile
the nice cells that were activated with
the cd3cd28 beads
secreted very high levels of interferon
gamma
in response to the target cell
the patient outcomes after the infusion
of nice cells
were encouraging the frequencies of the
gene edited
in tcr engineered cells remained quite
stable
between day 10 and 4 months post
infusion
there was also an increase in the
expression of genes
associated with the central memory
phenotype
these data are not shown here
samples were collected from patients
between three
and nine months post infusion and
expanded in the presence of new york eso
one antigen
antigen-specific cytotoxicity was
assessed
by chromium release assays and was
observed
in all patients the ct scan from one
patient
also showed a 50 regression
of a large abdominal mass
these case studies illustrate the
diverse applications
of maxsites technology in the car tcr
field the non-viral approach
discussed here is robust safe
and cost-effective the mrna car
therapies in resting and activated
t-cells
and also in nk cells are efficacious
with no serious side effects
it is possible to generate potent
piggyback transposon
cars that can be translated rapidly
to the clinic gene editing can not only
be used to generate
allogeneic cell therapy products but
also to improve the efficacy
of an already existing cell therapy
product
at macsite we have a partnership
approach to our science
we have a globally distributed
goal-oriented
field applications and sales team
we have a very experienced in-house r d
team we also have a skilled
quality and regulatory affairs team who
handle
our fda master file and quality
documentation
macsite's expert platform is more than
just a technology
it is a solution
thank you for listening and for your
patience
i can now take your questions
all right thank you rama so much for
your informative presentation
i'd like to use the remaining portion of
the session to now ask rama any
questions our viewers might have
so if you have a question you'd like to
ask please just do so now by using the
ask a question box located at the far
left of your screen
all right let's get started so rama
does maxsight have experience with other
transposon technologies
and if so what is the technology and
what is the performance
related to the technology
uh hi leslie can you hear me can
everybody hear me
yes rama okay great so
yes the answer is yes maxsite is working
with
a lot of companies with their
proprietary
transfers on technologies and also with
other pi specifically working with
sleeping beauty based uh car products
and other
piggyback transposons or piggy bat
transposon technologies so this
technology is used in both activated t
cells as well as
in cd4 and cd8 positive t
cells we have seen from our data from
the customers that we do get superior
transfection efficiencies when compared
to
lentiviral transduction of transposons
so i would say like we have efficiencies
that are consistent
and reproducible and some of the groups
have reported
well over 70 percent efficiency in
transfecting transposons okay
next question how does mrna-based gene
delivery systems
work when it's transient it may not give
a sustained
efficacy against tumor or relapse so
what is the argument behind this
approach
that's a really good question uh because
i presented so many case studies
on mrna transfection so
so the argument is you would think of an
mrna
car approach is more like a hit and run
approach like you would see with
bi-specific
antibodies and other
you know antibody therapies but
specifically
how the advantages of doing the mrna
therapy
is you will have to do repeated
infusions of the mrna car product as we
saw
in our case studies and the advantage of
that
is as you know car therapies and tcr
therapies to a lesser extent but car
therapies typically have a lot of
serious side effects and cytokine
release syndrome
and such that are evident when
the in the prolonged expression of car
gave given using viral vector
methodology so mrna
therapies can control that so since they
are given as
repeated injections one can actually
stop the injection
when the patients succumb to
some kind of cytokine release syndrome
and as evidenced in some of our case
studies
we have seen pretty efficacious
and robust response that is very target
specific and not
of tumor of tumor toxicities as seen in
the first clinical trial
with epitope spreading so that was
really successful
okay great um rama you had mentioned
the cryo preservation as part of the
workflow during the mesothelion car
case study what are the effects of
cryopreservation on the mrna
carb-modified t-cells
so so maxsite has a number of cell
therapy approaches
not just with rtcr but with other
disease models as well where we use mrna
to deliver the therapeutic
uh product so so
we have optimized the culture conditions
and electroporation
parameters for these uh delivery of
these mrnas
into resting or activated t cells or nk
cells
and then we find that when in the course
of optimizations we find that when
these cells are thought they
actually don't you lose their car uh
potency
and efficacy and so that's how we
and the viability is also retained so we
promote this kind of therapy using our
instruments
okay next question does electroporation
need to be optimized at scott moss gale
using the atx system before scaling up
to the gtx system
well that is a good question the answer
is no because you can
so the gtx system can be used
from for electroporating or optimizing
conditions from
by using cells at
even 50 000 cells or 75 000 cells all
the way to 50 billion
cells so you don't really have to use a
research grade instrument
uh like an atx to optimize
prior to moving to a gtx you can stick
with the same instrument
and go from your research scale
application all the way to
clinical or commercial scale
okay next question can you explain how
mrna
car electroporation compares to
retroviral transduction and ex vivo
expanded mk cells
so in the case study that i showed
with dr campana's group he actually did
a head-to-head comparison
with a gamma retroviral transduction of
a
cd19 bbc car delivered
as either a gamma retrovirus or as an
mrna
and in that study he showed that
the car expression following retroviral
transduction was about
60 percent whereas with the mrna car he
consistently got
about 87 and since nk cells
tend to be short-lived he decided to go
with that
approach as a viable option
for his clinical trial
okay great another question that came
through about
construct size so is there a limit that
can be
electroporated effectively into cells
regarding the construct size
okay is this question in relation to car
tcr
particularly or just in general
so if it is in relation to car tcr the
case study
that i showed with the transposon car
that those constructs are 6 kb
roughly each we do get efficient
transduction
transfection efficiencies to 8 or 9 kb
of car
dna but then for protein production and
other applications we have gone
we have electroporated much larger uh
sizes
and for viral vector production
sometimes the size is also very large
so yeah all right that's helpful
another question has come through about
cytokine release syndrome and its effect
on
car t cell therapy can you speak to the
cytokine release
syndrome effect rama yes so
cytokine release syndrome is a common
side effect that's found in car
therapies it's to a lesser extent in tcr
therapies but basically
when a car therapy is really effective
you get you know massive uh in the
course of tumor elimination and
recruitment of
all the immune cells you get a release
of a number of cytokines il-6
particularly
that causes high fevers and patients and
is commonly called as the cytokine
release syndrome
and um that that's like a commonly
seen side effect and most
virally induced car therapies
okay effective good yeah okay
next question does maxite's
electroporation process
affect the cell surface receptor
expression on nk cells
okay so that's a good question so the
maxsite electroporation
process is a fairly inert process
so according to the published data the
people that have used this
instrument for not just for uh nk
car expression but for other
uh you know adcc related studies done in
nk cells they basically found that there
was no effect
after electroporation on any of the
cell surface receptor expressions like
nkg2d
or cd16 that was evaluated by facts
analysis
post electroporation
okay next questions regarding viability
so
a customer typed in what is the
viability of the cells
12 and 24 hours post ep
so so this is in relation to
mrna transfections or
dna transfections it does
yeah okay yeah so so mrna transfections
is well as we all know you know in
immune cells mrna transfection does not
affect viability at all
and it's usually well in the 90s
either six hours post transfection or 24
hours
uh post transfection uh dna
uh you know immune cells are pretty
resistant to taking up dna
as such so dna does affect
viability but it also depends on the
concentration
of dna used so there's a linear
correlation between the amount of dna
and viability so the large as you
increase the amount of dna this dna
related toxicity
so let's say for example 100 micrograms
per mill of dna you would not see that
which is what we see
in dr yagyu's work which had over
86 percent uh viability post
dna transfection and that was two dnas
the transposon and transpose that was
uh that were co-transfected i don't know
okay
it does thank you um next question can
the maxite flow electroporation
technology
be integrated with commonly used culture
systems to create a fully closed process
yes so that is a really good question
and the answer is yes max cite
the any of those instruments the
atx well the atx is usually a research
grade instrument so the flow
electroporation technologies that
basically require higher uh cell
manipulations
can be sterile welded
into with other devices like the direct
devices that's commonly used for growing
t
cells or wave bioreactors which is done
downstream of the electroporation
process
or it even is bio welded quite well with
the
miltoni system so yes the answer is it
can be sterile welded
and can fit into the workflow of a
customer pretty easily
okay next question um is about the
electroporation parameter so
customer typed in can these
electroporation parameters be optimized
or modified
in the expert platforms yes
so this is correct we do
so the way we work with our customers is
typically
we provide as much guidance as
possible to the cell therapy customers
and give them a list of
optimized protocols depending on the
cell therapy
that they are engaged in but we also
provide a list of
optimization protocols that the cell
therapy
customer can use independently of us
to try to optimize their own conditions
so yes okay um we have another question
that came in what
about the cytokine release syndrome
again so what is the chance
of cytokine release syndrome effect
using mrna car t
therapy okay so that's a good question
so
the cytokine release syndrome is sort of
proportional to how effective the car t
therapy is so even if you're using an
mrna
carti therapy and it is really effective
then you might
get cytokine syndrome but the
the advantage to mrna car therapies is
that
that can be controlled which in a viral
vector
methodology it leaves your hands once
you
have infused the viral vector car that's
constitutively expressed
in the patient whereas in an mrna
therapy
that can be controlled by the number of
infusions that you can
give a patient so if the patient is
there is visible cytokine
release syndrome effects then the mrna
therapies
the infusions can be stopped so it's a
more controlled environment
okay now the next question that came in
does maxsite have a cgmp compliant
electric creation buffer
yes so we have just one buffer that
comes
with our system and that one buffer
works with
almost all the cell types except for i
think
with with the algal cells where we had
to
use a different kind of buffer but
basically the max site electroporation
buffer is
cgmp compliant it's produced by high
clone
for us and they do it with the
cgmp you know all the regulations that
that go with the cdmp compliance
okay and then i think this probably
might be the last question unless we get
any more after this one but
are there any clinical trials or
products in the market using
uh your non-viral approach
yes so as i showed in the
um in in the talk uh
we ourselves are engaged in a in a
clinically
max site ourselves engaged in a karma
clinical trial that's ongoing
and we do have a number of customers
that are using
our technology in in a variety of ways
in the clinic
whether it's in transposon therapies
they're either well
on their way into getting into a clinic
they're
working on their pre-ind filing or
they're
in their non-human primate studies and
will
very soon get into clinical trials or
um with we are also as i mentioned in
the last case study
a number of our customers are using us
in
allogeneic approaches uh that are
already in clinic right now so we
are upstream of the car process or
downstream where we
uh used to delete the the
track b2m to create an allotment product
so the answer is yes and there are other
other car therapies
that are non-viral therapies that are
also
well on their way to being in the clinic
or already in the clinic
okay great so it doesn't look like we
have any more
questions coming in so um with that i'll
go ahead and actually wrap up the
session um so i wanted to remind
all of our audience members that the
recorded version of today's talk
will be made available soon after this
live session
so you will be notified via email when
it becomes available
on also any questions that were unable
to be answered today
via the actual live session the answers
will be provided to you
in the in in using the email address you
provided at the time of registration
as well any that come through during the
on-demand period
so before we go i do want to take some
time to thank rama for her very detailed
presentation
a thank you to the customers industry
partners for allowing us to share your
important work with the larger cell and
gene therapy community
and i also want to thank lab roots and
their supportive webinar team
for organizing and promoting our event
lastly i would like to thank you
our audience participants for joining us
today and for your interesting questions
we look forward to having you in
attendance at our next midnight
lab roots sponsored session on september
17th
featuring our scalable manufacturing and
nano vesicle delivering solution using
crispr cas9 rmps
so this will conclude our session for
today until next time
goodbye bye